it was October 2015 Josh Hansen seen
here on the left was in a bar with his
girlfriend moments later another man
Shane O'Brien on the right leaves his
group and walks over to speak to the 21
year old the pair had never met police
say this was an inexplicable
confrontation hidden behind O'Brien's
back a knife which he used to slit Josh
Hansen's throat the social worker bled
to death at the bar in East London for
years on and after an international
manhunt his family were in court as his
killer was sentenced to a minimum of 26
years in prison if we can save one life
keep one son by his mother's side ensure
one person gets home safely
when they would otherwise wouldn't have
we will have made the world a more
bearable place for three and a half
years Josh Hansen's family have been
campaigning to find their son's killer
Shane O'Brien became one of the world's
most wanted men after the murder he
calmly walked out of the bar and was
later spotted by new clothes before
fleeing the country on a private jet a
global manhunt ensued O'Brien posed as
an Italian with false documents going to
extreme lengths to change his appearance
he tattooed over his child's name
finally more than three years on O'Brien
was tracked down in Romania and
extradited to the UK thanks to the media
thanks to the public and all the law
enforcement that we've been able to
create pressure by putting his face out
there so he became basically an
untouchable commodity to those that were
supporting him and that's why we got him
back here to the UK and he's been
sentenced sentencing Shane O'Brien to a
minimum of 26 years in prison the judge
called this a grotesque violent and
totally unnecessary attack on an
innocent man adding that we may never
know the reasons why
O'Brien acted as he did Josh Hansen's
family have waited to find the man who
inexplicably stabbed their son it's
taken four years to get here today
justice for his family learning to live
without him they say will take longer
Ali fought excuse
I News